[Musique]
on
petit oiseau qui sont là farcies ou en
farce de 1,2 moult serbe de moult épicé
de sous un fin très dur at war ou un
blanc de poireau liés au miel et aux
raisins la renaissance veut que l'on
côtoie plus facilement de petits oiseaux
décarie des perdrix celle ci est plus
facile à manger en vérité on le roi ou
la cour de france va prise est toujours
manger ou côtoyé la viande qui vole en
direction de l'éternel la stat waro donc
que l'on coupe dans sa longueur
c'est pourquoi on le nomme très dur à le
très content rase avec le couteau celui
ci puisque c'est très à la mode va être
agrémenté de raisins secs et juste à la
fin est pour le lier un peu de miel
la tarte verte du courtil le courtil en
période de la renaissance et le jardin
potager la renaissance puisque le beurre
est impliqué maintenant dans notre
cuisine et bien va donner naissance
justement à une pâte bien plus légère
celle que vous côtoyez encore
aujourd'hui bien plus soufflé en période
de la renaissance
il n'y a pas de notion d' entrée plat
dessert l'on va disposer tous les mains
sur la table le sucré et le salé alors
vont se côtoyer dans une casserole l'on
va disposer le vin d'hypocras un vin
rouge cannelle gingembre girofle et
sucre lorsque justement ce vin est en
bouillon l'on dispose alors la poire que
l'on a au préalable
éplucher celle ci va cuire doucement
cocher dans cette préparation de vin
épicé le sucre à la renaissance qui fait
partie de toutes ces nouveautés des plus
précieuses il faut savoir qu'un pain de
sucre le sucre même et vendus au poids
de l'or léonard-de-vinci lors de grandes
banques est dressée imagine et fait
construire donc une vaisselle de sucre
tous les convives à la fin pourront
croquer pourquoi non leur assiette ou
leur verre
[Musique]